if somebody wants to have a surgery to
look younger what is it that makes
people look younger
yeah so
the thing is is that it's not one thing
so this is really the artistic aspect of
what i do
is that there are multiple things and
it's different for every face
that create a more useful appearance
and so as a result you know it's often
multiple procedures it's not one big
procedure and that's what i try to
stress the patients it's like a big
facelift or a big brow lift or lots of
eyelid surgery what makes people look
youthful it's not a lot of surgery it's
little bits and details throughout the
different portions of the face and
that's what makes people look youthful
but also natural
and normal because obviously the biggest
fear is is that we're going to do
plastic surgery and we're going to look
at freakazoid
you know people don't want to look like
interest celebrities that they've seen
who've had plastic surgery
they want to look like themselves
potentially a little bit more enhanced
but arguably like they did maybe 10 or
15 years ago
so the thing is that often for me when
i'm doing a procedure it's a combination
of things the thing that i'm most well
known for
is for doing face lifting surgery so
it's called a deep plain facelift it's a
procedure that i pioneered and i lecture
that all over the world i publish
textbooks on it but with that is often
things that are done like a temporal
lift to rejuvenate the upper brow eyelid
surgery to help smooth contours lip
lifts because unfortunately as we age
the lip groups and the upper lip becomes
elongated fat grafting to add volume to
places in the face where people get
sunken as they get older so it's really
an artistic endeavor what i'm doing is
i'm looking at the face and i'm creating
creating contour and balance
and that's what makes me look young
so it's kind of a difficult question to
answer and i apologize that the answer
was so long
well that makes that makes sense though
um
so when you do these procedures do
people come in and they have a whole
bunch of things done at one time or do
they come in every six months
yeah it really depends on the
personality in the patient
what i definitely notice is that most
patients do i'd say 70 to 80 of patients
do it all at one time
and i think that's just because of the
you know the recovery time required you
know if people are going to go and take
that much time away from their normal
life for recovery i.e social activities
work all those things they don't want to
have to you know have seven
seven seven to ten day recoveries they'd
rather try to see if it can be done at
one time but those are busy people who
have lots going on in their lives and
then there are other people where
they're not so motivated they have a lot
of free time and they'd like to chip
away
and do a couple of procedures at a time
or one thing at a time there's no right
answer um you know you can do it either
way but i think that in modern modern
era and you know what we're dealing with
people want to be able to get things
done and then be able to move on with
their lives and enjoy the outcomes of
the surgery not make it a project that's
going to take them two years to get
through you know and 10 weeks of
recovery they'd rather be like going you
know saint bart's for a you know a
vacation versus you know sitting home
and recovering and being bruised for
that period of time
so did you say seven to ten days
on average most most recoveries for most
of these procedures you can get out
about seven to ten days afterwards it
doesn't mean you want to be you know
hosting a dinner party in your home with
people that you don't want to know about
surgery but functionally the majority of
my patients even professional patients
physicians attorneys people or financial
bankers they get back client facing or
in front of people at around 10 days i
tell them if they can get two weeks it's
ideal
but you know it's hard so you can cheat
it in 10 days and we have ways of making
the recovery much faster today that just
weren't available 10 years ago so i have
things that i can do
you know techniques and instruments and
and you know and lasers that help
recovery get rid of bruising you know
there are different uh treatments that
we do one of them is hyperbaric oxygen
treatments where you go into a
hyperbaric oxygen chamber every day and
increases the blood supply and the
oxygen content of the tissue so the
healing is much faster and i've learned
these things because a lot of my
patients
need to be back in front of cameras
really quickly i take care of a lot of
people who have public faces and as a
result i needed to figure out a way to
get them back to work quicker because
they don't have a lot of down time
between you know shooting you know
shooting television shows or other
things you know
what percentage of celebrities are
people who have tv appearances who are
you know in their 50s or 60s have had
work done do you think oh so pretty much
everybody who's post who's 50 and above
has had work done
so if somebody men too
yeah men kind of can cheat until about
late 50s early 60s so there's definitely
an unfair um you know unfair disparity
between men and women in terms of the
way they age
women generally speaking around 50 start
to age more rapidly and by 52-53 their
face really changes
that's because women go through
menopause on average at about 50 to 51
years of age and within two years of
that change
the facial tissues drop so unfortunately
there is a big change and a shut off
that happens for women that accelerates
their aging process so on average
most women will consider this if they
don't aren't more proactive about doing
it around 50 because they notice that
things just don't hold up nicely the way
they used to
men get to get a pass it's usually
around 60 that this stuff really starts
to come apart so i usually will treat
most men later 50s to early 60s and most
later 40s to early 50s
so that's when i kind of see it but if
you see a celebrity
who's in her early to mid 50s and she
looks youthful she's had surgery
it's nobody escapes this unfortunately
i've been doing this for 20 years and
i've done about 4 000 facelifts
nobody escapes this and it doesn't mean
that they look abnormal because with
good surgery people look natural like
themselves but youthful
but you can't be 53 years old and look
like you're 40 without surgery it
doesn't happen
okay so it's not all olive oil then
okay i don't want to comment on that but
it's not a oil
i guess i just did
olive oil it's not in recommends i mean
you know i i give these excuses to my
patients you know when they say well
what am i going to say when people tell
me how great i look i said well if you
look natural you won't say anything you
tell people you lost weight you've been
drinking green juice you know you've
been doing more meditation people
associate a youthful but natural
appearance with good health
so it's very easy to blame it on things
like olive oil your diet your
antioxidant drinks your your vitamins
you know a new skincare regimen because
if you look normal
nobody really gets it it's only when you
have the distortion
and the classic look that comes with you
know more antiquated
facelift surgery or plastic surgery that
it gets a big alarm
so i give people these excuses all the
time like yeah just tell people that you
did these three things you know or that
you had a little bit of botox or you had
someone that you know i intense pulse
like there would be treating your
dermatologist's office it totally throws
people off because they're not really
looking at surgery
they're looking at somebody who looks
good and healthy and youthful and they
want to know what your secret is but
they don't think it's surgery they think
it's lifestyle choices
okay so what are the what are the
downsides here
like is is this type of thing
super invasive is it dangerous and just
do you need to go under general
anesthetic no so we don't use your
anesthesia at least i don't a lot of
surgeons do but we do something called
twilight sedation which is where you get
a little iv they give you some medicine
that just makes you kind of sleep but
you're not paralyzed with the two of
your lungs breathing gas so it's not
something where it's like a heavy
anesthesia that's very risky um
obviously all surgery has risks so it's
not risk-free but the thing is is that
when you're with an experienced
practitioner your risk of having a
significant complication from surgery is
probably less than one percent and even
then those problems if you have one
can be managed and remedied